[Applause]
billy eilish is a 100 percent certified
hottie that's all i'd say to be honest
with you just check out the 19 year old
singer living her best life watching
megan the stallion set at the austin
city limits music festival
[Applause]
the video posted to billy's instagram
story on monday is proof that she's a
big meg fan and wants the world to know
it
and get this the love is so mutual
megan saw the clip and reposted it to
her story along with four heart eye
emojis
just for good measure let's watch it one
more time
[Applause]
now billy's love for meg is hardly
anything new fans of both singers will
recall billy used her record of the year
acceptance speech at the 2021 grammys to
publicly praise megan insisting the
award really belonged to her
telling the body singer who was seated
in the audience in part quote you
deserve this you had a year that i think
is untoppable you are a queen i want to
cry thinking about how much i love you
which is so incredible and it was so
amazing and in september when the bad
guy singer was named as one of time
magazine's most influential people of
2021 it was megan who wrote billy's
tribute
calling her so real and laid back even
though her personality is so big and
says after meeting at the grammys megan
knew she had found a kindred spirit that
night quote a woman who stands up for
herself and advocates for women
everywhere
[Applause]
last month both stars stunned at the met
gala marking their debuts at fashion's
biggest event of the year
billy who co-chaired the event told e.t
about her look
you are giving me marilyn monroe vibes
young lady is that what you were going
for this is a little bit yeah
you are also coaching what does it mean
to you
it's
like the most insane honor you would not
believe yeah i feel like
i'm in a dream
i feel like i'm like tripping
you said that you were feeling a lot of
nerves is that yeah like good ones
though like nothing literally not one
bad i just seem like this is the most
exciting thing i've ever done and meg
she said her glam was a whole moment in
and of itself
what was it like getting ready for an
event like this
um very different than getting ready for
my regular rapper lights off how so mad
i feel like we were in glam for a long
time yeah how long
i don't even know we've been in glasses
yesterday
like i was gonna wear my hair different
and we just landed on this so i'm like
okay